being an entrepreneur isn't enough when
you want to excel in your startup in all
arenas and that's where upskilling comes
into the picture the digital marketing
course prom simply learn watch all I
needed to elevate my Knowledge and
Skills
hi I am Ajit Kumar palai and I belong to
governation odisha and I am the founder
and CEO of a startup named Eco Sati I
recently of skilled myself with the
postgraduate program in digital
marketing from Simply learn after
completing my VTEC from triple it
publisher I worked for four years and
six months in a Consulting path but I
always wanted to get into
entrepreneurship I I have been a very
environmentally conscious person and I
always wanted to do something to
contribute towards protecting nature and
reducing pollution so basically Eco Sati
is a social e-commerce platform wherein
very sustainable products are sold while
working on it I realized that it's
really required to expand the reach of
my startup so I need to work on its
marketing aspects so as to improve the
business performance so I decided to
upscale myself and took the postgraduate
program in digital marketing principala
the course enabled me to work as a
freelancer digital marketer and to
generate a passive income as it is
undoubtedly a growing field the simply
learns course what I took provides a
very comprehensive and well formulated
curricula with the top notch industry
experts as instructors so in this
scenario digital marketing plays a vital
role in branding and marketing ecosathi
and generating Revenue as well for us so
learning new skills can never go in real
especially when you are a working
professional